So, in particular, the way I heard you write it down was that
A must consider the sort of worst case counter strategy by B right?
>> I see, because when A chooses the row, then B was going to
make things bad for A along that row, so that's the counter strategy you mean.
>> Right, and in fact, when you try to do it the other way with B. Well,
B has to do the same thing. B has to consider the worst case counter, as well.
And in this particular case, the way we set it up.
Where the values for A. A is always therefore trying to maximize.
And B is always trying to minimize A. Which works out
to be the same thing as maximizing itself. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah! I mean, other than the fact that, you know, I name
my first child Max. I really wanted to name my second child Min.
>> [LAUGH] That actually would have been pretty cool. Why didnt you do that?
>> Because I'm married to someone with more sense then i have.
>> Yeah i understand, i completely understand. Okay so, A is
trying to maximize B is trying to minimize they both have
to consider the worst case that the other will do. And
so whats thats going to is going to force them through exactly
the same process you went through. We just figure, I'm going to
make the choice so that my opponent makes the counter choice,
the worst case choice. I will end up as best as
I can. So A is going to basically try to find the
maximum minimum, and B is trying to find the minimum maximum.
>> Hmm
>> In fact that strategy has a name, or that way of
thinking about it has a name. What do you think it's called?
>> The minimum, maximum.
>> Yes, or Mini max.
>> Which is movie production company, I think.
>> No, that was Miramax. Do you recall
that where you have seen Mini max before
Michael? In some other class that you once
taught or once took years and years ago?
>> Mmm. No.
>> Mini max was exactly the algorythm that
we use for game search. And intro to AI.
>> Oh, which was a game tree, which is just what we
started with in this case. Even though we turned it into a matrix.
>> Exactly. So
in the end, we, you know, this matrix induces a game tree, if you want to
think about it that way. Or, game tree
induces a matrix, if you want to think about
it that way. And the strategy then, in sort of basic AI search, and the strategy
in game theory is Minimax when you're in
a two player zero sum game of perfect information.
>> So is there a way to do alpha beta pruning on this?
>> All alpha beta pruning does is gives you a more efficient
way of finding the answer.
>> I see but it's the same answer no matter how you set it up.
>> Right. Cool.
>> That's right. Okay, so this is pretty cool.
So, we have set up a kind of game
where we have multiple agents, you know, or at
least two agents in this case, who have different
strategies. And we actually sort of know, [SOUND], you
know, sort of, in a world where it's a
zero sum game, and you know the other person
is trying to minimize what you get, maximize what
they get. That the mini-max strategy would actually
give you sort of an answer, in this
case, by the way. We say that the value of this game for a is three.
If a does the rational thing, and b does the rational thing, that is trying to
maximize their own value, you will end up
in this situation. That's kind of cool, don't you think?
>> Very cool. I feel like there should be a theorem.
>> There is in fact a theorem. I'm going to write it down.